bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés ce soir
nous allons parler d'un paquet un pas
qui est entrée en vigueur officiellement
le 20 mai je parle bien sûr du paquet
neutre de cigarettes la neuveville la
nouvelle excusez-moi mesure phare du
projet de loi santé du gouvernement pour
lutter contre le tabagisme
objectif décourager les plus jeunes et
des français en général de fumée le
paquet neutre sera-t-il efficace
alors que certains et notamment les
buralistes le critiquent déjà cette
mesure sera t elle suffisante pour
combler son objectif
faut-il l'accompagner par une hausse du
prix du paquet ou un soutien à la
cigarette électronique pour répondre à
ces questions trois invités sur le
plateau
jean-françois vigouroux vous êtes le
président de la chambre syndicale des
buralistes des yvelines en face de vous
loïc josseran professeur des universités
praticien université de versailles saint
quentin en yvelines et renault nadja le
président du syndicat des pharmaciens
des yvelines vous êtes également
pharmacien à rambouillet bonsoir à vous
trois et avant et avant de vous donner
la parole messieurs on va voir à quoi
ressemble ce nouveau paquet neutre à
l'écran vous le voyez s'afficher
normalement voient la couleur et format
unique pas de logo nom de la marque
réduit messages sanitaires a grandi
jean-françois vigouroux vous êtes
vous-même duras liste à maurepas et
votre configuration votre fédération
s'oppose à ce projet de paquets neutres
qu'est-ce que vous inspire ce paquet
qu'est ce qui vous gêne dans ce paquet
concrètement bas pour nous le plus
difficile ça va être de la mise en place
et travaille avec parce que
j'ai pas si vous imaginez tous les
paquets identique avec bien sûr la
marque qui sera caché dans le linéaire
c'est sur ce goût très compliqué mais je
tiens tout de suite à dire que la
confédération n'est pas contre la santé
publique
on est pour si vous voulez on est pour
s'il faut trouver des solutions il faut
retrouver mais faucon qu'on ne soit pas
cavalier seul au niveau de l'europe
ça veut dire que sur les faits annoncés
de réduire drastiquement la consommation
de tabac vous dit peut-être mais c'est
sur la forme que ça ce non je ne crois
pas enfin on verra surtout grâce à ce
pas ce nouveau paquet neutre une
incidence du tabac qui vient de
l'étranger
alors vous vous passionnez d'entre vous
parliez d'europe le problème c'est quoi
c'est qu'en france on est les seuls à
faire cela en sera le seul à offrir le
paquet totalement là il ya l'angleterre
je crois qu'il ya des buts en deux temps
mais quoi qu'il arrive on sera la france
l angleterre il me dit que forcément on
va plus se tourner les français qui sont
frontaliers vers c'est à dire que on n'a
pas une politique européenne identique
l'europe demandé de faire 65 % de
mentions sanitaires et nous on demande à
toujours faire plus en france c'est tout
mignon s'est jamais assez il faut
toujours je ne pense pas que ça sera la
solution qui fera baisser la
consommation de tabac surtout chez les
jeunes loïc jeux seront en qualité de
spécialiste professeur de santé publique
est également membre du comité national
contre le tabagisme que vous que pensez
vous de cette instauration du paquet
neutre que vous soutenez officiellement
voir le paquet neutre est une très bonne
solution enfin forcément je ne peux pas
être du même avis que que la
confédération des buralistes c'est
évident le paquet neutre est
effectivement une vraie réussite en
matière de santé publique c'est un
élément fort c'est quelque chose qu'ils
visent et c'est là qu'il faut pas se
tromper ça vise avant tout les jeunes
il faut bien voir que les jeunes plants
si ce sont les consommateurs de demain
l'industrie du tabac a besoin des jeunes
sachant que un sur deux de ses
consommateurs va disparaître de sa
propre consommation de tabac il faut
forcément remplacés en permanence les
consommateurs qui disparaissent donc la
meilleure façon de les attraper
aujourd'hui c'est le paquet le paquet
c'est un élément publicitaire absolue il
faut savoir qu'un fumeur montre en
moyenne par an un fumeur d'un paquet par
jour montre sept mille fois son paquet
par jour par an pardon donc c'est
quelque chose concernant mon sort c'est
un élément publicitaire c'est un élément
attractif ça attire les jeunes il
s'échange sur twitter ou sur d'autres
d'autres réseaux sociaux des photos de
leur pack et il se collectionnent enfin
voilà donc le aujourd'hui l'élément de
publicité qui subsiste de façon en
dehors des points de vente
c'est le paquet et donc c'est normal
qu'on s'adresse aujourd'hui qu'on aille
aujourd'hui chercher le paquet neutre
est qu'on aille dans ce sens là c'est
quelque chose de très fort de très
efficace et on n'est pas les seuls au
niveau européen il ya l'angleterre et
l'irlande y en a d'autres qui
réfléchissent la norvège l'australie a
déjà largement été dans ce sens là ils
ont réglé ne peut pas voir ils ont réglé
des livres y pensait que ça allait
remédier sanaryens jeudi abc 6,8 alors
je saurai terminer et on va rebondir sur
l'australie ne doit pas dire que ça rien
fait ça n'a pas l'australie c'est le
premier pays à avoir proposé le paquet
noté 2011 premier pas qui voit le pays
qui en décembre 2012 a instauré le
paquet notre au prix d'un combat
son nom face à l'industrie du tabac qui
a attaqué l'état australien qui
finalement a perdu voilà et mais qui a
néanmoins des résultats pour on peut pas
le nier aujourd'hui on peut pas nier on
va donner la parole aux six à renaud
nadja est votre point de vue à vous sur
ce paquet neutre on parler de l'effet
marketing
est-ce que ce que déjà cet effet là est
important pour les jeunes est ce que
c'est vraiment attrayant de voir un
paquet rouge ou bleu et c'est pour ça
qu'on fume principalement vous savez
quand on voit un cow-boy derrière une
marque connue de cigarettes
c'est l'esprit d'appartenance c'est
devenir grand c'est de faire comme les
autres et fumé y compris pour nous
autres qui avons fumé ou qui fument
encore au démarrage c'était de faire
grand donc de faire grande d'appartenir
à une à une caste voilà donc je crois
moi pour revenir sur la notion même du
paquet neutre que tout ce qui va dans le
sens de la santé publique est quelque
chose de très bien
l'augmentation du prix du tabac certes
nos collègues buraliste à chaque fois
effectivement parce qu'il ya une
entreprise derrière et que et et qu'il y
ait une défense professionnelle ça me
semble normal mais le sujet numéro un
c'est quand même la santé publique
pourquoi aujourd'hui où tout se met en
oeuvre pour donner de la vie à la vie
pour essayer de vivre le plus longtemps
possible pourquoi s'en prit
s'empoisonner volontairement
voilà c'est parce que derrière ce tabac
notamment en plus quand ils sont plus ou
moins aromatisés il y a des plein de
produits nocifs
jean-françois à venir ou vous avez
entendu les arguments des professionnels
de la santé qu'est ce que qu'est ce que
vous répondez non écoutés
oui votre manière c'était évident qu'on
ne soit pas contre 6 ans c'est le but de
votre venue à claques à l'australie
comme l'intervenant précédent on disait
que l'australie ça a marché
faut simplement pas oublier que
l'australie c'est une île même si tu es
une grande in en france on n'est pas sur
une île et on a des frontières
alors oui ou oui à une taxation
supérieure n'y a pas de problème on peut
nous inventer ce qu'on veut vous ne
dites pas qu eric comme notre cher
ministre à 10 euros pourquoi pas mais
tout le monde va 10 euros c'est tout ce
moment on veut que tout le monde soit
pareil quand vous voyez que nous on le
paye 7 euros que d'autres c'est 6 20
regardez en allemagne en allemagne ils
ont encore droit publicité sur le tabac
et pourtant il ya moins de jeunes qui
fument que nous donc faut plus peut-être
de la prévention mais je pense pas que
aujourd'hui si un français peut aller
acheter son tabac en europe hier à fumer
du tabac allemand c'est une minorité de
français qui avait mis la barre un
puissant voilà que même les ombres on
perd à tous le paquet neutre vous le
disiez messieurs c'est principalement
pour pour les jeunes ce qui veut dire
que celui qui fume depuis 20 ans va
continuer à fumer de la même façon ou
alors il y aura un effet également
dessus celui qui fut exaucé en même
temps celui qui fume depuis 20 ans il
continuera à fumer le jeune et on le
voit bien les ça a été montré à de
multiples reprises à travers x
publication
n'attire le paquet notre n'attire pas le
paquet mode n'attirent pas les jeunes
n'attire pas donne même pour les fumeurs
les plus anciens leur donne dans des
proportions extrêmement importante plus
des deux tiers lord envie de réduire
leur consommation et c'est ce qui s'est
passé d'ailleurs en australie la
consommation des fumeurs a été réduite
il fume 13% - ils ont une prévalence
minutes contrebande qui s'évalue qui
remonte et qui se ressent salon mais par
des étrangers par le passé ça que je
viens en france paris répond c'est pas
vrai vous le savez vous et moi les mêmes
les douanes le disent et les douanes on
peut pas les soupçons des prisons si son
nom ils ont saisi s'écoute les douanes
arrêtez s'il vous plaît les douanes ça
n'est pas 25% qui sont des sites qui
sont des chiffres donnés par les douanes
c'est 6 5% et 6 5%
les douanes que vous mélangez commerce
illégal contrebande
oui et commerces 30 français mr paul de
vence frontalier où il ya du
transfrontalier légale durant certains
tags illégale et vous ne pouvez pas
aller contre la légalité des choses on
comprend on comprend vos positions à
chacun je voulais vous entendre sur une
autre proposition qui a été évoquée par
la ministre de la santé marisol touraine
d'augmenter pourquoi pas le prix du
paquet pour atteindre peut-être un jour
es10 euros certains disent qu il faut
coupler ces deux mesures et qu'il
faudrait augmenter le prix d'une façon
importante est ce que vous partagez au
6e ce point de vue renault nadja
augmenter le prix du dollar qui rend
plus d'instaurer le paquet neutre est
très franchement aujourd'hui je ne
connais pas d'incidence du de
l'augmentation du prix multiplié par dix
ou vingt ans donc ce qui est déjà pas
mal on était à 1 euro 50 dans les années
90 et on est passé à 7 euros en 2015 on
voit là à l'antenne tout de suite
allez-y vous ai compris mais en fait si
vous voulez il ya deux sujets c'est
premièrement comment empêcher les plus
jeunes de commencer et comment ce vrai
les plus âgés qui sont déjà dans un
parcours tabagique voilà les deux sujets
de santé publique ces deux là et est-ce
que autour de ça vous ne l'avez dit
peut-être un peu de prévention peut-être
aussi de la prise en charge
plus plus musclée j'allais dire dans
tous les sens du terme c'est pas
uniquement financiers économiques autour
des fumeurs aujourd'hui qui encore une
fois malheureusement se retrouve avec
une patte deux des pathologies qui sont
pas ce que vous avons prises en charge
le plus musclé plus musclée
psychologiquement d'accompagnement des
changes peut être une prise en charge
aussi au niveau du sevrage tabagique en
règle générale en moi je suis plutôt
j'ai été parmi ceux qui râlaient
notamment avec l'interdiction de fumer
dans les lieux publics et va aujourd'hui
je trouve que c'est très bien c'est très
bien pour tout le monde et ce surtout
parce que les enfants s'y adapter c'est
surtout très bien pour mes enfants
donc et quand vous voyez les petites
cabines ne vous états unis les fumoirs à
droite et à gauche et que vous voyez là
l'opacité de l'air et qu'on imagine ça
dans nos poumons
donc on peut se poser des questions et
encore une fois par contre il faut
avancer de façon égalitaire pour tout le
monde et que certains qui ont pour
métier
cette distribution là ne doivent pas
être les seuls payeurs en bout de chaîne
jean-françois vigouroux quand vous
entendez la mise de la santé évoqués
éventuellement une augmentation du prix
du paquet elle n'a pas fixé de date ni
d'augmentation mais beaucoup de
spécialistes disent que c'est le moyen
le plus efficace avec le paquet neutre
pour faire baisser la consommation de
tabac là aussi j'imagine que c'est des
volumes ça c'est sûr c'est certain
maintenant celui qui ont timidement
toujours même avec un paquet à 10 15 ou
20 euros cas à 10 euros
ils m'ont toujours moins certainement
mais alors celui qui a toujours fumer ça
me paraît difficile d'arrêter peut-être
que c'est surtout pour les jeunes ne pas
les mettre deux ans maintenant vous
savez entre ce qu'ils fument ce qui sort
de chez nous et ce qu'ils attrapent un
peu dans la rue
vous savez je ne sais pas ce qui est bon
et ce n'est pas bon mais leur dire
aujourd'hui vous arrêtez dessus mais je
pense que ça va être un problème
même pour les jeunes non mais de façon
le le prix le prix du tabac est
effectivement le deuxième levier
particulièrement efficace et même
peut-être plus efficace que le paquet
neutre il ya ce qu'on appelle une
élasticité négatif dans le prix d'un peu
plus près augmente et plus la demande en
regard baisse il a été déjà montré à de
multiples reprises que c'est
effectivement efficace efficace à partir
du moment où ça atteint un certain seuil
et ce dont on se rend compte sur les
dernières années alors il ya une partie
les premières années du plan
duplan chirac entre nîmes et du plan
cancer ont été très efficaces avec des
augmentations de prix massives qui ont
eu un impact réel sur la consommation on
sait pertinemment que
les plans qui ont suivi et les années
les années entre guillemets sarkozy ont
été beaucoup moins efficace de ce point
de vue là puisque certes y ait eu des
augmentations mais qui ont été juste
suffisante à grossir les bénéfices
fiscaux
les bénéfices de l'industrie est
également la marge des buralistes mais
largement insuffisant pour avoir un
impact sur la consommation donc en gros
il ya une limite aux qu'il se situe
autour de 40 centimes en deçà de 40
centimes on sait que c'est pas efficace
ça fait gagner de l'argent tout le monde
mais ça n'empêche personne de fumée
qu'on parle d'une hausse du prix du
paquet ou d'un paquet neutre à chaque
fois on s'attaque à ceux qui
potentiellement pourrait arrêter de
fumer mais je reviens à ce qu'ils font
depuis vingt ans comment on peut les
aider éventuellement à sortir de la
cigarette du tabagisme
c'est ce que prévoit notamment le le p r
nt qui a été qui a été votée récemment
en rendant plus accessible en formant
mieux les professionnels de santé en
rendant plus accessibles les moyens de
sevrage
c'est par ce biais là et est néanmoins
et quoi qu'on en pense le prix aussi
joue moi je connais des fumeurs anciens
qui le prix augmentant les fait aussi
réfléchir mais c'est sûr qu'il faut
former mieux les professionnels de santé
au sevrage rendre les dispositifs de
sevrage plus accessible ce sont ce sont
les meilleures solutions aujourd'hui
pour réduire cette consommation vous qui
êtes buralistes la vente de tabac ça
représente combien de pourcentage de
votre chiffre d'affaires est ce que
c'est un chiffre qui diminue beaucoup
s'il faut pas confondre chiffre
d'affaires et qui volume donc
dernièrement les chiffres qui étaient à
la baisse
stein maintenant mais il a surtout le
plan vigipirate et le renforcement
frontières aussi un peu
stoppés comment agit mais bon ça une
part importante dans l'économie
d'entreprise n'était qu'un parce que
vous quand même pas oublier qu'on a des
salariés est bon est ce que tout ça est
ce que tous aient tous ces plans là vous
pousse à à dire on souhaite notre mort
aujourd'hui
oui et puis comme comme le disait tout à
l'heure le monsieur sait que on est le
dernier maillon de la chaîne
alors à chaque fois on stigmatise quoi
c'est le buraliste c'est le vendeur de
mort etc
monsieur disait c'est pour augmenter nos
marges n'augmente pas de marge augmente
nos commissions c'est parce qu'on est
commissionné sur un secteur où il ya
combien de d'euros 2 centimes d'euro sur
vienne avoue 45 à 50 centimes sur un
paquet de 8 à 10% si mais si sa course
en 7 % sur le tabac finalement si on
insiste du prix du paquet de cigarettes
peut être quelque part bénéfique pour
vous à nouveau subir une hausse
c'est ce que je vous dis c'est qu'on va
baisser en volume peut-être qu'on a
baissé en volume pour gagner un peu
moins mais pour limiter la casse mais ce
qu'on veut nous c'est que mettez le à 10
euros demain pas de soucis métallos
partout que les gens soient pas tentés
d'aller à l'étranger ce que vous oubliez
enfin de préciser c'est qu'il y à il ya
également des plans d'avenir qui ont été
décidées qui ont quand même mais aussi
financer largement l'industrie
enfin le monde des buralistes pour
justement dans un premier temps et ça
c'est ce qui avait été décidé au début
des années 2000 pour contrebalancer la
perte possible en termes de chiffre
d'affaires pour vous il y avait ce plan
d'avenir qui prévoyait justement de
compenser la baisse potentielle cette
baisse n'est pas forcément intervenus de
cette façon là
derrière il y avait un deuxième plan
d'avenir qui est arrivé ça fait je crois
que les buralistes ont été destinataires
de quasiment 2 milliards et demi d'euros
il ya un troisième plan et un troisième
plan et un troisième plan qui en cours
qui va s'arrêter juste fin 2016 pour
être négociée juste avant les
présidentielles de façon à avoir une
marge là aussi un même la cour des
comptes révèle enfin je pense que c'est
pas forcément tout ça n'est pas forcé je
voudrais évoquer maintenant avec vous
une autre facette du débat et de cette
loi santé et de cette lutte contre le
tabagisme la e-cigarette où la cigarette
électronique
il sera désormais interdit d'en faire la
publicité est ce que c'est une bonne
chose aussi de durcir la loi sur ce
sujet là alors que certains disent même
des spécialistes que les e-cigarettes ça
en moyens de sortir du tabac dit
classique et que c'est aussi un moyen de
lutter contre le tabagisme
aujourd'hui des produits pour le sevrage
tabagique qu'il n'a certain nombre avec
un apport en nicotine puisqu'au
finalement on est devient addict à ce
produit là et le deuxième la deuxième
addiction cette geste
donc si on favorise le geste et qu'on
maintient le geste de fumée et de
continuer à utiliser cet outil qu'il
soit électronique ou pas eh bien je
pense qu'on a fait encore une fois que
la moitié du chemin ce qu'il y avait à
chercher le 0 tabac ou alors plus le
loin de tabac vous le savez aujourd'hui
il ya une vraie question est aujourd'hui
les pharmaciens aux particuliers et
l'ordre national des pharmaciens
interdit la commercialisation de la
cigarette électronique pourquoi parce
qu'on sait pas ce que ça donne parce
qu'on n'a pas suffisamment de recul
parce qu'il y à un certain nombre de
mélange qui sont faits avec une sécurité
et je voulais quand même aussi puisqu'on
parle de ça de parler aussi de la
sécurité parce que le tabac
certes c'est un produit dangereux mais
on est dans un circuit en france qui est
un circuit encadré et il y a de la
sécurité il ya de la responsabilité de
la part des buralistes qui ne vente pas
à n'importe qui n'importe comment
ça leur est imposé et derrière il ya de
l'économie ça a été dit tout à l'heure
donc tout ça
un beau mélange autour de la cigarette
électronique d'aujourd'hui et les
produits que l'on met dedans et que l'on
hilal faut pas oublier que les poumons
c'est quand même un des organes qui
absorbe le mieux toutes les saloperies à
la voile donc et et donc in ad quelque
chose c'est de temps en temps on dit ça
sent mauvais aulas je me mets un
mouchoir et là on avale d une fumée de
je ne sais trop quoi on dit de l'eau
mais j'en ai dr françois lamoureux va
être la réaction sur cette filiale
électronique est tout à fait d'accord on
aura les méfaits de ceux de ce produit
là dans quelques années dans dix ans a
sauvé on se dira peut-être même c'est
plus dangereux qu'à ses gars est parce
que ça fera peut-être du mal sur
d'autres organes
en tout cas les poumons c'est sûr parce
que maître de la vapeur d'eau avec des
produits dans les poumons je sais pas si
c était bon dans un autre mais je pense
que c'est quelque chose qui marche bien
par exemple dans votre on le fait chez
eux
votre bureau de tabac je sais pas c'est
pas un grand chiffre ça a été ça a
démarré très fort
et puis beaucoup on va dire sur sur
disque acheté une cigarette électronique
il y en a cinq qui vont laisser dans la
table de nuit quoi donc qui sur les 5
restants il a leur a permis quand même à
pas mal de baisser en cigarettes
maintenant est ce que c'est un bienfait
où il va y avoir une compensation du mal
par un autre je sais pas locke je sens
votre point de vue sur la sig à tel
point qu est ce qu il faut aussi la une
moi j'veux pas cibler la tenir on est
même du coup d'accord avec monsieur
passé c'est moi je suis je suis pas je
suis loin d'être un grand adepte de la
cigarette électronique
effectivement on sait pas on sait pas où
ça va où ça va amener on ne sait pas
même si
les fabricants jurent leurs grands dieux
que c'est fabriqué de façon sécurisée de
façon convenable et c'est qu' aucun
risque particulier que ça n'est que de
la vapeur d'eau dans laquelle on ajoute
quelques trucs qui ne protège qui ne
pose aucun problème d'un point de vue
d'un point de vue de santé loin loin
loin s'en faut
rien n'est encore certain la deux le
deuxième problème et c'est ce que c'est
ce qu'évoque c'est qu'ils étaient
évoqués précédemment
c'est que effectivement il ya une
gestuelle et qu'on est toujours et ça
c'est le problème vis-à-vis de la
cigarette électronique et du tabac c'est
qu'on est dans une forme de
normalisation à nouveau alors qu'on
travaille depuis des années à des
normaliser la consommation de tabac et
l' usage à travers la restriction dans
les lieux publics à travers la publicité
à travers ce genre de choses on cherche
à dénormaliser le tabac là au contraire
la cigarette électronique et des partis
pour renault rebaptisée et faut pas se
tromper
l'industrie du tabac a racheté
énormément de fabricants de cigarettes
électroniques et c'est pas par hasard si
ils investissent ce marché là
aujourd'hui c'est un marché qui peine
effectivement qui a probablement
quelques difficultés il arrive peut-être
à maturation après après une embrouille
dans une envolée lyrique il ya quelques
années on sait pas non plus comment ça
se comporter vis-à-vis des jeunes est ce
que c'est une porte d'entrée vers le
tabagisme est ce que c'est un moyen d'en
sortir pour les plus gros fumeurs
voilà ça peut être un outil de sevrage
ces vrais faux pas ne faut pas le nier
mais il ya encore énormément de points
d'interrogations quant à 7 à 7
ce dispositif alors là on évoquer les
mesures les plus connus les plus
répandues une mesure choc qui pourrait
aussi être employée dans le futur ce
serait d'interdire de fumer partout dans
la rue et autorisé finalement que quand
privé est ce que c'est une mesure qui
pourrait voir le jour ça demain et qui
aurait du sens pour lutter contre le
tabagisme interdira de fumer à tout le
monde partout vous savez plus on mettra
deux barrières
mieux on n'atteindra sans aucun doute
l'objectif qui est de 2 passes et donc
dans d'autres pays ça a été interdite et
va les gens continuent - mais pour ceux
qui veulent absolument fume et boit fume
sherman et on reste là que nous ne pas
fumer dans la rue c'est pas mal non plus
de ne pas trouver de ceux de mégots
partout
enfin trouvé nommé bourse à nouveau et
avoir un certain non je voudrais juste
revenir de seconde sur la cigarette
électronique a été assez précis donc
l'ordre national des pharmaciens
déconseille fortement voire interdit la
commercialisation de ce produit
je vous rappelle juste qu'un médicament
est inhalée il faut dix années d'études
pour savoir ce qu'on va donner à
quelqu'un
et là il ya des produits qui circulent
on ne sait pas d'où ça vient
on ne sait pas ce qu'il ya dedans voilà
et roule
jean françois bugaut rousse cette
possibilité de donner pouvoir de
cigarettes dans l'espace public tout
l'espace public
ce que vous pensez que c'est ce que
cache ce plan de lutte contre le
tabagisme en août a fait un moyen terme
sont elles craignent et kate on n'est à
l'abri de rien c'est un sujet dont vous
parlez avec des collègues peut-être
encore pas encore mais ils ont bien vu
dans les jardins d'enfants tous ces
interdits bon ami tu as à fait
compréhensible - ils suivent l'exemple
maintenant que ce soit par tous n'est
pas encore loïc josseran se diriger al
sainte cassel s'enregistre à ce je ne
sais pas je sais pas je suis pas dans
les petits papiers de de l'avenir de
l'avenir et j'ai pas de boule de cristal
mais il n'empêche que c'est un moyen
dénormaliser si l'industrie veut placer
ses produits de façon aussi visible à la
télé au cinéma dans les films et
téléfilms etc
c'est bien justement que la vue d'une
cigarette créer cette attirance et créer
ce besoin de fumer et attire les plus
jeunes on revient toujours à ça donc
plus ondes et normalise
moins on en voit mieux c'est je voudrais
vous entendre sans un dernier point
puisqu'il nous reste quelques quelques
minutes pour pour cette émission sur
l'objectif que s'est fixé le
gouvernement avec son programme national
de réduction du tabagisme aboutir en
2032 à ce que les enfants nés en 2014
constitue la première génération sans
tabac concrètement est-ce que c'est
réalisable ou alors c'est surtout pour
faire beau ce genre d'objectif 2032
c'est pas si loin c'est faisable ça
qu'en 2032 les enfants comment 16 ans
ou 18 ans plus tôt on peut l'espérer on
peut l'espérer il faut se donner les
moyens de le faire faut aussi rappeler
que le tabac c'est quelque chose de en
dehors de la dangerosité qu'il qu'il
représente d'un point de vue sanitaire
c'est aussi un marqueur social
extrêmement forts qui touche les
populations les plus faibles
c'est à dire que un fume un chômeur sur
deux fument bien travaillé dans 60 des
chômeurs fallait donc c'est oui mais
donc c'est vraiment quelque chose de
très particulier dont il faut
effectivement pouvoir et et ya un
phénomène social dans la consommation de
tabac les plus riches ont commencé les
plus riches aujourd'hui avec le tabac
est aujourd'hui les plus pauvres ont
commencé derrière les plus fragiles ont
commencé et j'espère que les plus
fragiles vont aussi s'arrêter maintenant
jean-françois vigouroux sera convoyé un
tel objectif du gouvernement
oui mais ça me paraît absurde
enfin après de faire baisser de faire
baisser la consommation des jeunes
pourquoi pas mais ça rentre aussi par
l'éducation mais bon faut pas la
prévention et à l'éducation si l'enfant
voit ses parts en fumée je pense pas que
c'est pas en allant voir les films mais
si son père fume dans le salon ou dans
la voiture il parlait aussi de faire un
projet de loi d'interdire de fumer dans
les voitures sur donc voila mais bon je
veux dire après tout ce qu'on a
tellement mis en scène la voiture c'est
un univers clouera par là mais on pourra
refaire éventuellement une émission
dessus puisque on arrive à la fin de
cette émission merci à vous trois
d'avoir répondu à toute cette question à
toutes ces questions et d'avoir
participé à cette émission vous pouvez
retrouver justement cette émission en
podcast sur tv fil 78 points comme bonne
soirée à tous